die flut und ist so was ja schon immer
sein wollte die stimme des meeres
das meer es kennt unendlich viele
geschichten zwei drittel unseres
planeten sind von ihm bedeckt von seiner
bedeutung zu erzählen ist genug stoff
für ein ganzes leben
nikolaus gelpke hat sich dem mehr
verschrieben und liebt es immer wieder
anders aufs meer zu schauen sommer am
strand warum nicht mit einer reportage
aus dem iran so zu denken ist genau nach
seinem geschmack
optik verschiebungen sind seine sache
das meer hat erkrankt und darum hat
themen nach erkrankt
das meer ist mehrere nicht unbedingt
maritim betrachtet über schifffahrt oder
über satellit oder über helfer sondern
wir machen ja alles je mehr die gesamte
it vom meer vor sie kulturufer slava und
das ist unhandlich fließen
und so gibt es unbeeindruckt von den
stürmen in der presselandschaft seit
fast 20 jahren eine kulturzeitschrift
die eine lücke geschlossen hat
ein bedürfnis
in der hamburger speicherstadt dort wo
das meer schon zum greifen nah ist
verwirklicht der gebürtige zürcher mit
seiner redaktion einen traum er
bleibt seinem konzept treu je schneller
die welt wird desto mehr haben die
menschen freude an langsamer erzählweise
an ausgeruhten reportagen an der
gegenströmung zu mir getrennt
was mich was ist möglich gemacht für
mich es flüchtete vor der hektik von der
vielfalt vom unkonzentriert vor allem
das was mir ab lang vom lager
ich glaube das hat zur folge dass man
als schweizer verhältnisse zu wählen
wahlberg hat aber viel sehnsucht nach
und nach die die nach der wärme nach dem
wasser sowieso und ich glaube das macht
finden muss
als kleiner junge wurde nikolaus gelpke
in den ferien von einer großen welle zu
boden gedrückt seine mutter geriet in
panik er genoss es der kraft des meeres
ausgeliefert zu sein
er verschlang die bücher und filme des
abenteurers jacques cousteau wurde
später meeresbiologe und
forschungstaucher lernte respekt demut
vor dem er auch vor seiner
unberechenbarkeit
am meisten aber hat in die freundschaft
mit der jüngsten tochter thomas manns
elisabeth mann borgese auf die spur des
meeres gebracht
die kosmopolitin die autorin des
alarmierenden buchs das drama der meere
sie war charismatisch kämpfte lebhaft
für die rettung der weltmeere
in ihr erkannte gelb für sich selbst und
seit ihrem tode führt er ihre arbeit mit
den von ihr gegründeten organisationen
fort wie etwa dem international ocean
institut
gelernt dass man im prinzip keine
transfer rät und dann sah man immer
wieder mit gleicher sache
blüte zähle
der lebensraum meer ist bedruckt
aktivisten zeigen uns bilder die unser
ferien bild stören nikolaus gelpke war
früher auch bei greenpeace engagiert er
kennt die schwierigkeiten die bedrohung
des meeres zu vermitteln wenn es über
aktuelle katastrophen hinausgeht
plastiktüten sehen wir
aber die erwärmung und noch
dramatischeren bedrohungen nicht
denn wir landbewohner betrachten das
meer immer aus unserer perspektive
wir wissen über das meer weniger als
über die oberfläche des mondes so
scheint es die dimensionen der ozeane
sind uns kaum bewusst dafür will uns
mare sensibilisieren wir machen das so
wie sie damals in rieti wir bitten große
zeigefinger sondern
eine rate von der sinnlichkeit spielend
dass das was wir machen da freut macht
so dass man das gefühl hat man es als
erstes immer spaß macht es sind
geschichten über menschen die mitte mehr
leben für das meer
seit einigen jahren erscheinen im mare
verlag auch bücher romane über das leben
am meer und dokumentierte geschichten
des lebens
wie im buch der kurs der kennedys das
gerade erscheint
um das wirken der kennedys zu verstehen
sollte man ihrer leidenschaft für das
segeln und das meer betrachten das leben
auf dem familien boot der viktor steht
für alles was die familie aus machtkampf
freiheitswillen unterstützung
fürs leben lernen wo kann man das besser
als auf dem meer kombination aus
emotionalität und rücksendung der eplus
zum ihre böse schlappe diese kombination
ist beim thema und erfasst hat weit über
los laut
aber vielleicht das ganze halt noch ein
bisschen romantik kraft sobald ich mehr
bin ich wieder genauso wie wir früher
noch einfach immer fasziniert von der
möglichkeit dass der horizont sitzgurte
ganze für alle romantiker ich weiß gar
nicht genau definieren
es ist eben wieder da
das mini ist ein unerschöpfliches thema
je mehr geschichten er darüber
veröffentlicht desto stärker spürt er
wie die menschheit vom mehr abhängig ist
diese überzeugung trägt nikolaus gelpke
weiter
das mehr als geschenk können sie bei uns
haben wir verlosen diese woche